でもこの基本なければまた帰って瞑想は修行することもできませんしね
だからこの攻撃性良くないというストーリーがありまして
このあるあの金の作業するこのアクセサリー作る職人がいて
で それまた大変なプロで王様の仕事やってるんですね
ですから この彼がもう家家柄の家の仕事だから
まあ生まれた時からもう金やら銀やら宝石やら
そういうものしか朝から晩まで他のものを扱うということはないんですね
まあほんのちょっと時間があったらご飯ぐらいでしょうと
ですから この他の人から仕事を頼まれても
あの醜いおばあちゃんが私にアクセサリー作ってくれというふうに来るわけじゃなくて
若い人々が女の子たちが来て
あのアクセサリー作ってもらったりするんだから
まあそれで本人もこの美しさという目でものを見て
アクセサリーなどを作らなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことだから 頭にあるのはいつでももう綺麗という感覚だけなの
彼が一応全部嫌になって出家するんですね
サーリプッタ尊者のところで
サーリプッタ尊者は智慧の第一人者なんですね
で サーリプッタ尊者は簡単に忙しい方だからね
もうお釈迦様よりも忙しかっただろうと思いますけどね
で あ この人はこういう性格だから
じゃああなたは不浄の瞑想しなさいと言って瞑想を教えてもう帰っちゃったんです
この人は不浄の瞑想するはするはするはするはするはなかなか微かにの心は成長しないんですね
それでまあサーリプッタ尊者もあまりにも有名で偉いんだからね
もう大胆な先生のところに弟子入りしたんだから
そこで失敗したらもう行くとこないんです
究極なところに行ってしまったんだから
そこでなかなか瞑想もうまくいかないということで
本人がもう落ち込んでということは
私はもうダメだと 適性ないんだと
仏道においては だからサーリプッタ尊者置いといて
他の先生のところに行って
あの瞑想はちょっとまずいんだから
うまくいかないんだから
他のことを教えてくださいったって
もうできませんでしょうね
サーリプッタ尊者よりふさわしい人がいませんだから
他の坊さんたちはもう何も言わない
サーリプッタ尊者に言われたならば
もうやりなさい それ以上何もないと言うんですね
そこで彼が還俗しちゃうんですね
そしたらそこにサーリプッタ尊者より偉いお釈迦様が出てくるんですね
出てきて なんであんた還俗
一応挨拶に来たとこで
私はやっぱり在家に戻りますと
在家に戻って普通の修行して徳を積んで
まあ来世でも修行して悟りたいんだと
今世は無理ですよと 才能ないんだと
うん ということで じゃあ 1 日だけ待ってくださいと
1 日だけ待ってくださいということで
お釈迦様が まあこれ仏教の物語だから
お釈迦様は自分の神通力できれいな蓮の花を作ってあげたんだと
というふうな話ですけど
まあそこら辺にあったすごい立派な花があっただろうと思いましてね
そこにあったすごい立派な花
じゃあこれあんたにあげますからと
それ持ってそこら辺に座っていなさいと
還俗は明日でもいいんだからねと
お釈迦様に言われたら
じゃあ 1 日待ってくれと
待ってくれって なんか仕事あるみたいな感じなんですね
別になんのことなく お釈迦様花 1本取って
じゃあこれ持ってそこら辺ちょっと座ってかけてなさい
それだけ それでその人
お釈迦様からもらった花で
すごくありがたいし またこれすごい立派な花ですからね
それ見た途端 ものすごく喜んでしまっちゃったんですね
なぜならば ずっとこの綺麗なものしか見たことがないんだから
こんな汚い体のこととか
痛い見たりしたっても
もう慣れてないんですね
あれ見たところで すごくお釈迦様のところも綺麗なところで
大変聖なる場所で そこら辺座って
じゃあこれちょっとということでしたから
それ見るといきなり動じてしまっちゃったんです
動じたところで じっともう彼が我を忘れてこの花を見ているんですね
花見てるとみるみるうちに花がどんどんどんどん枯れていって
で もう枯れていっちゃうんですね
それと一緒に彼が悟るんです
完璧に ですから これサーリプッタ尊者が失敗したか
どっちかちょっと言いにくいんだけど
やっぱりこのストーリー出しているのは
ただ単に攻撃対立姿でも良くないという話なんですね
瞑想の場合は でも逆にもっと考えちゃうと
ずっと綺麗なものばっかり見ていた人がにはものすごい精神的なショック
慣れてない とんでもない
全く逆の世界の経験を長い間させてさせてさせて
心はどうしようもない
もう自殺するぐらいのところに持ってきた可能性もありますね
もう何もわけもわからない
自分の仕事の世界もプロ
プロとして育ててきた
その人生そのものを否定されてやって
世の中の事実はこんな醜いものやと
あんたやってたことは何もない
くだらないインチキではないかという話でしょうに
人に金のネックレス作ってあげて
その人は何者ですかと
死んじゃったらこんなもんだよと
だから自分の人生そのものを否定されちゃったんですね
サーリプッタ尊者に で
それでもうどうしようもないところで
じゃあもう全部終わったと
この人はもう何にもよりどころはない
家に好きで戻るわけでもない
家に戻ったっても落ち着かないんですよ
もう全部否定されているんだから
その人が もう家に戻って
また仕事に精を出しますよと言ったっても出せませんでしょうに
ですから そういう準備があった上で
お釈迦様がじゃあはい
この花を持ちなさいと
そこでまあきれいかきれいじゃないかとか
そんな話もなく やっぱり世の中美しいものだという幻覚もなく
なんとなく見たところでじっと心が統一してしまって一体になったと
サマーディが生まれたということで
それサマーディの落ち着きで花を見ると
花がどんどん消え枯れていくんだ
あ これは事実やと 別に物事はきれいじゃ汚いかということは
ある人の感覚であって
実はきれいか汚いということではなくて
物事は瞬間瞬間変化しているものだけで
そんなものにいちいち執着されて捕まれて束縛されて苦労する必要はないということで
心は解脱 完全たる解脱を得たんです
ですから あのストーリーで完全にサーリプッタ尊者が失敗しましたっていうことも言いにくいんですけどね
二人組であの人にとってはすごいプログラムを作った可能性もあります
その人を悟る場合は こういうからくりでやらなくちゃいけないんだと
まず基本的にはこの人をもうダメにして否定してしまって
この自殺するところまでもう存在感を消してしまって
それで道を教えた方がいいんじゃないかなと
ということの方がもっと正しいかもしれませんだけど
そういうふうに思った方が
とにかくそのストーリーは
ブッダゴーサ長老が出しながらいいのは
言いたがっているのは
やっぱり対立的な 教育システムだけいつでも効くわけじゃないという話なんです
でもまとめて言うのは
やっぱりそのその個人にはぴったし合うプログラムはある
瞑想のプログラムはあるということなんです
あの次のところは この 280ページの 14番目のところも
このチャートを見れば
全部別々に理解できると思います
瞑想の区別ですね この瞑想というのは心を育てることだから
この心を育てて この集中する目的なんですね
この集中の段階は一応 3つに分けているんですね
この心 集中する強さというのは 3つに分けているんです
その 3つの問題の1つはこの落ち着いたという一般的なこと
それだったらどんな瞑想
40種類のどんな瞑想でも落ち着くんですね
心は これ一番基本的なレベル
我々の日常生活の例で言うならば
喫茶店でいて その喫茶店でガンガン音楽をかけていっているんだと
人々あっちこっちいっぱい満員で
ものすごい大きな声で喋っているんだ
だから落ち着くどころか
もう体の細胞までものすごくどんどん混乱してくると
そこでその場所場を離れて
一人も人が何もない公園に行ってベンチに座っているんだと
このベンチに座ったところで
じっと心が落ち着いてしまうんですね
で それぐらいの落ち着きっていうのはもう簡単に得られるでしょうし
で 子供はものすごく泣いていると
何か何か物を見せたりして
おもちゃ見せたりしてね
で 興味を他の方に持っていけば
それで落ち着いてしまうと
そうやって日常生活の中でこの対象を変えれば
ある対象から混乱が生まれると
その対象を変えて違う対象を求めていったら当然落ち着く
ですから この 1番目のレベルで言っている
この心を混乱なし落ち着くというレベルが 40種類の瞑想からも出てくるんですね
次のレベルというのは
このかなり落ち着く なんか体で心でじっと感じるところまですごく安定しましたと
ものすごく気持ちよくなったと
体も心もなんかすごく清々しい気持ちになりましたという
もうなんか他のことはもう考えられなくなったと
いろいろ雑念やら雑念やら出てこなくなっちゃったと
なんか自分を我を忘れてしまったというぐらい
ちょっと強力な落ち着きなんですね
それはこちらでは大体ウパチャーラという風な
ウパチャーラ・バハヴァーナというんですけどね
日本語ではこれが近業収拾と書いてますけど
で 近業と書いてますけどね
それは近業ではなくて
一応このサマーディに近いという意味なんですから
近浄でよろしいんですけどね
近浄なんですけど まあこちら近業と書いてますけどね
そういうのはこの翻訳をする人々がこの言葉を一つ一つカットしてカットして
それに漢字入れ替えるだけの作業なんですね
言葉の意味を翻訳しようとしないんです
ウパチャーラっていうのは側にいるという意味なんです
近寄ったという意味なんですね
何に近寄ったかというと
禅定に近寄ったという
ですから 近いという漢字の近と禅定の定入れて近定と書いた方が翻訳するってなれば
もう言葉としてはいいんですけどね
で あの金魚 金魚でもいいし近所でもいいしね
まあそこはこの大体どんな瞑想から生まれるかというと
ブッダヌッセティ仏随念など八種類
サンニャーワワッターナ
サンニャーっていうのは
この食べ物に対する瞑想と
地水火風に分ける瞑想などですね
そこで二つですね そこで十種類の瞑想がありますね
この十種類の瞑想で随念瞑想八とサンニャーという
この食べ物は不浄やという瞑想と地水火風に分ける瞑想という十種類
で その十種類でこの近定という状態が生まれてくるんですね
サマーディに近い とても近い状態が生まれてくる
これは世俗的な例で言うならば
私たちは例えばすごく外はうるさいんだったら窓を閉めておくと
あ 落ち着きましたと そこでものすごい激しく日が差してきて
もう部屋はものすごいもう気持ち悪くなってくると
じゃあカーテンを閉めて落ち着いてもらうと
というぐらいは まあ一応一時的な落ち着くなんですね
で そういうことじゃなくて
例えばものすごい大胆なこと起きたとする
その時は我々はいきなりそれに惹かれてしまっちゃうんですね
例えば何かどこかで誰かのパフォーマンス見ようとかね
有名な人のパフォーマンス何か見ようかなとかね
まあ言って まあまあそういう何と言いますか
うんと まあどこでもいいんですけど
まあ国立舞台なんとかがやりますね
能のやってるところとかね
まあどこでもいいんだけど
そこで行っていろいろおせんべい食べたり
飴を食べたり 隣の人と喋ったり
まあまあうるさくてね
いるんですね そこでまあ舞台のカーテン開けるあれもベルも鳴らすし
まあまあそれぞれいくらか落ち着くんですね
ジーンと鳴らしちゃうと
あと五分 五分のあれ印
まああと五分対応と開演までとなってもあまり落ち着かないんですね
それで一分の になって
また稽古の音が鳴る 稽古なんて言いますかね
で 舞台のアラーム鳴らすでしょ
そこで舞台上がるとみんなもう全部話
隣の人との話やめてこうやってるでしょうね
あれは一番目の統一状態なんですね
今までの話は全部終わって
もう目は舞台の方に行ってるんです
そこでまあ一応舞台はいろいろありますから
まあどんどんどんどん始まる
気持ちよく見ていて まあいくらか見てはいるんだけど
たまたまどうですかとかね
あれどこに置いたんですか？とか聞いたりする可能性もあります
ああいう飴もう一個ちょうだいとかね
あれも食べながら見ている
そこでいくらか時間経ったところで
みんな見たがったこの本人が現れると
本番というかね そうすると全部忘れてじーっともう見ているでしょうし
それなりにじっと見ているか
もう狂ったような感じで歓声上げたり
ああだこうだするか それはそれなりにどっちでもいいんだけど
やっぱりその時は我を忘れるでしょう
どの人が隣の人もうせんべいもう一枚どうですか？と聞いても聞こえませんね
そうやってステップ三つあるんです
そうやってサマーディの世界も同じく
この統一の力っていうのは段階を三つに分けているんです
それ段階三つに分けて
どんな瞑想からでも第一番目の統一性はできて出来上がります
十種類の瞑想からは第二番目まで出来上がりますと
そうすると三十種類残るんですね
残り三十種類から本当のサマーディまで第三段階まで生まれるんだと
我を忘れる すべてを忘れるところまで集中できるんだという話
それでこの我を忘れる瞑想にしても
これサマーディ瞑想なんです
それは三十種類なんですね
この三十種類のサマーディの瞑想の中でもサマーディのまたランクがありますね
第一禅定 第二禅定 第三禅定
第四禅定と それから無色界の四つ
また別にありますし この計算はそれほど合ってないんですけどね
なぜならば この無色界の四つの瞑想っていうのは
この近侍定とか何とか近定とか言えるものじゃないんです
無色界の瞑想は四つしかない
それは色界終わった人はやるものなんですね
例えば混乱状態の人がいきなり無色界の第一番目の瞑想をしようと思ったっても
それはありえない話なんですね
ですから そこでこの計算はちょっと問題なんですけど
そこでこの残り三十種類の瞑想の中でどれぐらい禅定作れるかと
第一禅定までか 二までか三までか四までか
もっと上へ行けるかということはまた区別できますね
アビダンマでは第四禅定ではなくて第五禅定まで行ってますから
こちら五まで行ってるんですね
そこでダサカシナ あの十種類の何とかカシナという瞑想ありますね
いわゆる パタウィヤポーテジョワーヨ ニラ ピート ロヒトーダータ
ダサカシナのカシナ十種類と書いてますし
こちらにありますからね
アーカサ アローカ パタウィヤポーテジョ ワーヨ ニラ ピート ロヒトーダータ アーカサ アローカという瞑想十種類あります
そういうのは説明はしましたからね
その瞑想 十種類の瞑想から第一禅定から第五禅定までできます
それから呼吸瞑想も同じく第一禅定から第五禅定まで呼吸瞑想もできます
そこら辺はこのチャートを見ると
もう説明なしに一遍にわかります
そこでダサアスバカーヤガターサティ
ダサアスバというのは不浄の十種類とこういうことサティ
あの心気づい-- 心気念
心気念と書いてますけど
これは随念ですけど で
心気 まあ随念かどっちかどうかは書いてないんですけど
この心気随念あるいはカーヤガターサティと上に書いているこの七番目のあの不浄の十種類
不浄の塔 その瞑想は全部第一禅定で終わるんです
で このチャートのその二というところを見てください
そちらに書いていると思います
その二のこの七番目書いてるところ
不浄の塔 不浄の十のな-- その塔と次に八書いてる随念の塔がありますね
随念の塔の中でこの心気随念という瞑想があります
で そこを全部まとめて
それから呼吸瞑想 そこは全部この第一禅定までなんです
あ 呼吸瞑想は書くいないんだ
ということは 例えばこの死体見て瞑想すると第二禅定が生まれる
第二禅定も作ろうと思ってもできませんということなんです
まあそれなぜできませんか？と説明はないんです
例えば体を三十二の臓器に分けて瞑想すると
もう第二禅定は生まれるですね
なんで第二禅定生まれませんでしょうかね
まあ説明書いてないんだけど
それすごいわかりやすいことで
このあれは概念瞑想なんですね
頭で考えて瞑想するんですね
第二禅定に行くためには言葉やめなくちゃいけないんですね
で 言葉やめて考えることをやめて
あのー あの瞑想できないんですね
死体を見ながら何も考えないでボケーとしていたっても
もう何の意味もないんですね
そこはいくらか考え 思考が働いたところで禅定が生まれるんです
そういうことだから 例えば呼吸っていうのは言葉なくてもずっと感じて持っていくことはできるんですね
そこで時々自分のことはこのあんまりにも高く高く評価している人々が
あの 私はこの言葉で瞑想するのはややこしいんだから
言葉なしにじっと感じたらどうですかと聞いたりはする場合ありますね
それで相手があまりにも高慢高くて
自分のことをすごく高く評価しているんだったら
まあどうしようもないんだから
まあやってみなさいとは言います
でもそれで瞑想は進まないんですけどね
大変なことには危険なことにはなります
それはもう承知の上で
やってみて危険なところに陥ったら
本人はまあ大変なことになったことと同時に
自我も高慢もいくらか壊れているんですね
じゃあそれだったらこういうふうにやりなさいと言えるんですから
で なんでそういうことを言ったんですかというと
このいきなり言葉なしに私は禅定に入って無念無生で瞑想するそうと言ったっても
法則変えることは人間にできないんです
物事っていうのは 自分というもので動いているわけじゃないんだから
宇宙の法則だからね 全ては
自分の心もまあ単なる宇宙的な法則だから
これ変えることはできないんです
ですから どうしても雑念・増念が生まれるんです
雑念・増念が生まれないのは
徹底的に心に喜びが生まれてきて
一つのものに集中している時だけなんです
一つのものに対象に粘りすぎちゃって
一体になって集中している時だけ
他の雑念する隙間がないんです
ですから 人はまず第一禅定で概念を持って瞑想を続けなくちゃいけない
そこで第一禅定できたならば
もう集中力はついてるんだから
もう雑念なしに無念無想の状態で第二禅定に頑張ることはできます
そういう順番なんですね
そこで無念無想で呼吸を感じることはできますけど
無念無想で遺体の観察はできません
そういうことで第一禅定で終わります
それでメッタ瞑想とカルナ瞑想とムディタ瞑想は第四禅定まで
慈悲喜捨の慈悲喜は第四禅定まで出来上がっちゃうんですね
第五は生まれません それもすごい厳密な理由があるんです
慈悲喜の場合は喜びが生まれるんです
友情によって喜びが生まれる
人を助けてあげる気持ちによって喜びが生まれる
人のことを喜ぶ時も当然ながら喜びが生まれてくる
喜びついている統一性っていうのは第四禅定までなんです
第五番目の禅定では喜びがないんです
それもなくなって捨の状態
平安な状態が生まれてくるんです
ですから 慈悲喜捨の慈悲喜の瞑想からは第四禅定まで瞑想できるんだと
ウペッカー瞑想からは第五まで禅定作られます
ですから このウペッカーの欄に
あの あの 丸四つ書いておいてください
第一 二 三 四も生まれるんです
こちら丸書いてないんですけど
[笑い]そこで無色の瞑想なんですけど
まあこの無色界の瞑想は
まあそのその無色界の禅定ですから決まってるんですね
一つしか得られません
例えば空無辺定では空無辺という禅定しか生まれませんし
色無辺の瞑想では色無辺という禅定しか生まれませんしということで
次にこの郷邪 境による別と書いてる
あのページ まあそこら辺そこまでいちいち言う必要ないと思いますけど
ルーパ・ジャーナと うんと
どんな方がいいか まあ一応郷邪だけ説明します
まあ郷邪っていうのはこの対象ということで
それほど複雑な意味ではないんです
だから統一性には三段階ありますね
一般的にまあ落ち着きましたと
なんかじーっと落ち着きましたと
それから禅定生まれたんだと
という段階ありますね
それはまあ一応こちらでなんとか言葉で
書いてるでしょうね 瞑想するときは何か対象ありますね
色の対象か死体かどちらでもいいんですけど
これを瞑想するんだと
呼吸瞑想の場合は 自分の呼吸自体が瞑想の対象なんですね
そこで仕事始まるんですね
吸います 吐きますと あるいは遺体を見て
それを見ながら一生懸命観察しながら瞑想始まるでしょうし
何か青い色とか持ってきて瞑想を始めたら
それはもう見ながら青い青い青いとか言葉かけながら瞑想始まるんですね
それはパリカンマ・ニミッタというんですね
それで統一心は落ち着いてきます
それでじっと落ち着いたんだという場合は
もうなんか我を忘れてこの対象を見ている状態なんですね
我を忘れて頭いっぱいなんで
その対象で ということは目を閉じても見える状態なんですね
目を閉じても瞑想対象見えると
例えば遺体見て瞑想したところでもう頭に焼き付いちゃったと
どれぐらい頭に焼き付いたところ
目を閉じても遺体はそのまんまで見える
そこで壁を見ても そちらに穴が開けてしまったり
そちらにも遺体が横になっているように見えてしまう
自分と一緒になってしまっちゃうんですね
それは統一性の第2番目の段階なんですね
そこで自分が対象を持ち運ぶと言うんです
普通の言葉で それは 例えばこのある場所で青い色の円盤を作って
それを見て瞑想してしてして頭に焼き付いたところで
その場所から離れるんです
離れてもっと楽なところに行って
どこかへ行って瞑想する
それでも本人にとっては明確にあの円盤が見えているんです
だから この物体的な瞑想対象から心でイメージをコピーするんですね
これは微かなイメージではなくて
はっきりしたイメージをコピーするんです
心で 心にコピーされちゃったら
統一性ある間はそれ見えるんです
遺体を見て遺体の対象をコピーしちゃったら
自分の部屋に入っても遺体を見える
そのまま あるいは電気消しても真っ暗で
その人に真っ暗くはないんです
自分の前で遺体がそのままあるんですね
だから部屋は黒いか明るいか
それも関係なくなっちゃって焼き付く
その対象はこちらで書いている 2番目の対象なんですね
だからそれと瞑想の方法と同じなんです
第2番目のステージステージまで統一性できる瞑想から第2番目の対象が生まれてくるんです
そこでこの第2番目というのは金城状態なんですね
そこで本当にサマーディ生まれる
瞑想も 30種類あるでしょう
で そこからは第3番目の対象が生まれてくるんですね
例えばサマーディが生まれると
この頭に焼き付いた対象ではなくて
もっと明確にはっきりしている対象が自分を吸い込んでしまっちゃうんですね
あるいは自分が対象に吸い込まれてしまっちゃうんですね
吸い込まれてしまって一緒になってしまっちゃうんです
そこは第一線上なんです
ですから 対象も 3種類あります
それも前と同じ言葉でパリカッマニミッタ
ウッガハニミッタ アッパナーニミッタと言うんです
で 日本語の言葉なんでしょうかね
その中では偏差相と主相とは偏差相
主相 それから似相 かな
一応パーリ語ではパリカッマニミッタ
ウッガハニミッタ パティバーガニミッタという 3つなんです
パリカッマっていうのは仕事をする時使う対象
修行 ウッガハニミッタっていうのはこれからコピーした対象
頭で焼き付いた対象 それからさらに瞑想すると
あの対象も変わってしまって
自分を吸い込むか対象に吸い込まれるかという一体感が生まれる
で そこを一緒になる瞬間の対象がこの似相というかね
何に似ているかというと
やっぱり禅定に似ているんだという意味で取っているんですね
それほど難しいことでは何のもないんです
そこで瞑想自体も 3種類あります
最初の瞑想はパリカッマ・バーヴァーナーと言うんですね
対象を持って一生懸命瞑想する
吸います 吐きます 吸います
吐きますと あるいはもう紙片とかなんとか取ったら
それを見ながら見ながらずっと仕事をする
それはもう第1番目の瞑想ですね
それで頭に焼き付いちゃったら
第2番目のステージの瞑想なんですね
それはウペチャーラ・バーヴァーナーと言うんです
そこをやっている途中で寸地にサマーディが生まれちゃうんですね
それはパリカッマ・バーヴァーナーと言うんですね
じゃなくてアッパナー・バーヴァーナーと言うんですね
暗示瞑想 アッパナー・バーヴァーナーというのは瞬間だけ
パリカッマ・バーヴァーナーにはすごい時間がかかる
これ何年かかるかわからない
焼き付いたらまたどれぐらい時間かかるかわからない
でもサマーディは瞬間に生まれる